Shanghai residents are finally out on the streets,
celebrating the end of a
strict two-month lockdown.
But it might not be the last time
they have to go through this.
As China clings to what it calls
a “dynamic zero-COVID strategy,”
people can face stringent lockdowns any time
there’s a rise in cases where they live.
In Shanghai, residents were basically
locked up at home for weeks.
Shops, schools and offices were closed. The
lives of 25 million people were put on hold.
The social and economic consequences of
these tough restrictions have been painful.
And the suffering might seem very unnecessary,
especially when the rest of the world
has basically returned to normal.
So why is China sticking to its zero-COVID policy?
The answer is that it has little choice.
China's failure to capitalize on its early
pandemic success and adapt to different
circumstances today means it's now stuck.
To understand why, we need to go back
to the very beginning of the pandemic.
Remember Wuhan, the city where the coronavirus
was first found? It was also the first city
in the world to enter a COVID lockdown. And by
December 2020, while most countries were still
battling devastating outbreaks, life for the
city’s 11 million people was back to normal.
That’s thanks to a strict lockdown that
was imposed right after the COVID outbreak.
In China, their first objective is to keep the
virus out of the community as much as possible
with travel restrictions. And then if
the virus does get in, which we know
will happen sooner or later when there's an
outbreak in a particular community, [it] does
very stringent control measures:
case finding, isolation of cases,
contact tracing and quarantine. And that's
facilitated as well typically by lockdowns.
Professor Cowling is an epidemiologist based
in Hong Kong – where pandemic measures have
been mostly in line with mainland China. The city
has been pretty much COVID-free until recently.
It's a very efficient strategy compared to other
strategies, because as long as most of the time
can be spent at zero daily cases, actually life
can be pretty normal inside cities in China.
In fact, China’s initial
approach was so effective that
it was regarded internationally as
a successful example to learn from.
Professor Jane Duckett spent
18 months with her team,
funded by the UK government, looking into
China’s pandemic strategy back in 2020.
I think it was successful in the beginning,
obviously, in the sense that they
got infections and deaths, death rates back
down to zero from around late March 2020.
But what was effective then is now less so.
With the arrival of the more transmissible
Omicron variant, it has become much more
difficult to stop the spread of the virus
– even with measures like lockdowns.
Countries like Singapore and New Zealand, which
initially adopted their own zero-COVID policies,
have changed tack and are now
trying to ‘live with’ the virus.
But China has not. Its success story back in 2020
has arguably become the biggest hurdle in the
way of a more flexible approach today, in 2022.
A major reason for China’s hesitation to open up
is that the vaccination rate
among its elderly population
is exceptionally low – and that’s largely due
to the consistently low number of infections.
I think in a sense the successful containment
made the vaccination, especially
of older people, seem less
necessary. Right? If you don't have it spreading
through society, you don't seem to need vaccines.
Only 19.7% percent of people above the age of
80 in China have received a vaccination booster,
while just over 50% of them have
completed their primary vaccinations.
I suppose you could say they trusted
the government to protect them…As long
as the zero-COVID strategy continues, then the
public health measures are limiting infections.
And so vaccines would be like a backup plan, but
maybe not an urgent priority for older adults.
A recent study published by Shanghai’s
Fudan University claims that,
with the currently low vaccination
rate among elderly people,
the lifting of the zero-COVID policy
could lead to over 1.5 million deaths.
China could have pushed for a more aggressive
vaccination campaign before the Omicron
variant appeared. Missing that window has
resulted in the struggle it’s facing today.
That wasn't really planning for
the future and wasn't really
planning for the contingency of a more
transmissible variant as we've seen.
On top of that, there’s the question of
vaccine efficacy. Research has shown that
the Chinese-made, inactivated-virus vaccines are
less effective against infections with Omicron
than mRNA vaccines, like, for
example, the Pfizer-BioNTech vaccine.
But China still hasn’t approved the use of
foreign-made vaccines for its population.
Instead, it is betting on
home-grown mRNA vaccines,
which are still undergoing clinical trials.
And that seems to be driven purely
by political decisions, you know,
political motives to not want to be seen,
to be reliant on international support,
international science and technology, but to be
able to develop their own vaccines and use them.
This possibility of high
death rates and infections
if China drops its zero-COVID approach is
just too risky for the ruling Communist Party.
A lot of how people see COVID, in 2020, 2021,
is in comparison with the West. So in countries
like the United States and Western European
countries, COVID rates were very high, death
rates were very high, people had waves of lockdown
and a lot of political disturbances. And it's just
felt like chaos in the West, whereas China was
relatively peaceful and had very low death rates.
Professor Nancy Qian is currently based in the US.
She has been observing and writing
about China’s COVID strategy.
And I think that's what the politicians
want to avoid and they just don't know how.
They can’t avoid it completely. They're trying
to find the path of minimal political cost.
And the political cost of abandoning
the ‘zero-COVID’ strategy currently
seems to be too high. It has become
President Xi’s signature policy.
He is expected to announce his intention for a
landmark third term at China’s 20th Party Congress
coming up in September – So it’s bad timing for
a gamble on a new way to handle the pandemic.
They think that they have demonstrated the
superiority of the system in containing the virus.
And therefore, they would like to continue with
that. And they think they can continue with that.
But the costs of continuing
with the policy are growing.
The stringent COVID strategy is taking its
toll – not only on people’s daily lives,
but also on China’s economy. And that too
will tarnish the ruling Party’s popularity.
Is there a way, then, for China
to both transition out of its
zero-COVID strategy and save the Party’s image?
I believe that it should be possible for them
to find a face-saving way to message this.
It's all about the messaging, to say:
Look, there is going to be some risks,
but if we don't open up, there are other types
of risks and other costs that we have to pay.
The difficulty is that the longer
they go on as they are now,
the harder it will be for them to do that
messaging effectively. Because the longer they
go on like they do now, the more unhappy people
are and the less people trust the government.
And this all leaves Xi Jinping and the Communist
party in a particularly tricky situation.
They do just seem to think that they can keep
testing and containing their way out of this.
However long term, It doesn't
look very sustainable.
There is going to be a political hit
no matter what. They can’t escape it.